bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france à leur première question
grigny est la ville la plus pauvre de
france selon l'observatoire des
inégalités
comment en est on arrivé là je suis pas
économiste un quart des finitions mais
en réalité vous avez un problème
aujourd'hui de sous investissement sur
certains territoires
il y avait des populations qui en grande
partie ne consomme pas localement et
vous travaillez également hors de ces
territoires ce qu'il avait dit qu'il est
l'égalité territoriale très fortes liées
en plus à travers le mouvement de
décentralisation et à travers les
inégalités en termes d'horaires et que
d'allégations de revenus qui sont bi à
un creusement des inégalités
territoriales
donc là c'est une vieille question qui
ne se pose pas cadrée mais qui pour le
coup est particulièrement marquant sur
certains territoires remettre de l'état
sur ces territoires là c'était l'un des
engagements qui avaient été pris par
jean castex et par exemple le g10 mais
grigny qui comporte des qr est un des
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
est ce que ce concept porte ses fruits
et ce qu'on peut en tirer un bilan
à l'heure actuelle pour l'instant
modérément encore une fois parce que nés
sur des politiques qui sont des
politiques d extrêmement longue haleine
pendant très longtemps ce que l'on a à
pierrot d'événements mondains impliquées
essentiellement de revoir la politique
d'urbanisme et d'envisager la mise en
place d'une structure qui veut des
structures assez isolé du quartier avec
pour objectif à travers un certain
nombre d'activités renouveler de
dynamiser un tissu économique il est en
bois aujourd'hui que ça relativement aux
fonctionner et qu'il faut passer à une
nouvelle que l'équipe de redynamisation
à travers l'installation de services
publics et à travers la capacité à
développer de manière
endogène des activités chimiques encore
une fois évalué ce type de bilan sur
quelques années même si évidemment du
point de vue de la communication
politique c'est toujours bon de dan et
six affiches et d'expliquer qu'on fait
quelque chose c'est beaucoup trop tôt et
le problème de ce type de politique
évidemment c'est que électoralement
présente il a difficilement des marins
du feu parce que ni les conséquences
sont à très long terme et ensuite parce
que on est dans des territoires où
l'abstention étant extrêmement
importante et bien généralement les
répercussions politiques sont
relativement faible souvent de
désintérêt de la part des politiques
nationaux au total ce sont 3 milliards
qui sont sur la table
selon l'exécutif est ce que ce sont des
mesures qui vous paraissent suffisantes
alors là encore une fois je peux aborder
la question d'un point de vue économique
mais du point de vue du moins pas de
politique mais du point de vue
économique une sorte de mon domaine de
compétence
est ce que ce sont des mesures qui sont
suffisantes
encore une fois des plans à plusieurs
milliards d'euros ou déjà été mis en
place
le problème c'est pas temps aujourd'hui
le montant de ces plans même si
évidemment qu'il est important mais
c'est l'orientation de ses plans et leur
capacité à redynamiser ensuite une
croissance et un tissu économique local
ça implique de un meilleur ciblage c'est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui semble
avoir été elle qui par les acteurs
publics
mais il ya de quoi alors l'exécutif
propose aussi de limiter à la
construction de logements sociaux dans
les 170 villes françaises où le seuil de
40% de logements hlm est atteint on va
donc en construire dans d'autres villes
pourtant le sec certaines ne jouent pas
le jeu actuellement
alors certaines ne jouent pas le jeu là
encore vous avez des intérêts électoraux
niveau look ou qui au niveau local qui
les conduit à ne pas vouloir
jouer ce jeu là or si vous voulez avoir
une dynamisation du tissu économique
comme je l'évoquais si vous voulez avoir
une un effet de mixage des populations
vous avez la nécessité justement d'avoir
une meilleure répartition sur l'ensemble
du territoire des logements sociaux
donc le fait que des communes entre
guillemets plus aisés se mettent de
manière volontaire aux logements sociaux
est une nécessité dans ce soit ça ne
règle pas tous les problèmes
le vrai problème de ces territoires là
c'est que ils sont devenus des hubs
c'est à dire que les gens qui s'y
retrouvent à éviter souvent attendent de
voir leur situation économique
s'améliorer pour pouvoir
l'équité est donc ce ne sont pas des
territoires dans lesquels vous vous
inscrivez et vous restez ce sont des
territoires qui sont des territoires
d'eau de transit vers ensuite d'autres
territoires qui lorsque votre situation
économique le permet et bien
apparaissent plus attractifs au revoir
chair de ces territoires des lieux de
l'attractivité est fondamental et
essentiel parce que sinon vous pouvez
toujours développer un parc de logements
qui ne soit pas un parc de logement
social mais c'est ce parc de logements
pourra pas forcément preneur étant donné
que encore une fois on n'est pas face à
des territoires qui sont vraiment ben
merci d'avoir répondu à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques mercier